okay jury selection has begun for the
elizabeth holmes trial today marking the
official start let's break down what we
know so far just for a quick refresher
obviously you know theranose was a blood
testing
startup here in silicon valley it was
backed by a bunch of weird uh
non-venture capital firms and it had a
bunch of people on the board of
directors who were old men from military
and you know senior cabinet positions in
politics it was really a technology
company backed by non-technologists and
you know uh within governance of old
white men it was really weird uh and we
all noticed that here in silicon valley
the uh ceo elizabeth holmes and the ceo
sunny balwani were jointly charged with
wire fraud and conspiracy to commit wire
fraud back in june 2018 they were also
in a relationship something i said on
cnbc i might have been the first person
to report that accidentally because it
was kind of an openly known thing
in silicon valley according to the wall
street journals um holmes is being tried
by herself not with bahwani um and this
is because of
the fact that she is now going to claim
a bengali defense that she is being
manipulated or she was manipulated
she faces a dozen counts of wire fraud
and conspiracy to commit wire fraud for
allegedly misleading investors and
patients about thorinosis technology in
other words when you got the blood prick
you supposed to give like one little
drop and they would tell you everything
turns out they didn't know anything they
were giving wrong results to people they
had to recant all of those blood tests
and they were also when raising money
from investors according to john kerry
ruse and many people's reporting and
witnesses
taking blood samples and then using a
different machine a commercially
available machine getting the results
putting them back into their fake
machine crazy i mean deranged behavior
both of them have pled not guilty
and if you want to check our prior
coverage of this there are no story i
really highly recommend episode 828 and
episode 617 when i had john karau on the
show so this is like 600 episodes i had
john kerry on after he wrote the first
story episode 617 and then when he uh
finally wrote his book which is amazing
he should have won a pulitzer for the
coverage here i don't know why he didn't
in episode 828 um and he john kararu is
doing his own podcast about this so you
should look that up bad blood the final
chapter i'm no expert on the law but
essentially
when you lie to people and you sell them
shares
and you take their money the money goes
over the wire and boom fraud
there you have it uh and holmes and
balwani are facing a maximum sentence of
20 years and a fine of 250 000
if convicted my god the fine seems so
tiny these days when and just out of
proportion when you know this is a 10
billion dollar fraud because that's what
the company i think peaked at in its
valuation and they raised hundreds of
millions of dollars
they've obviously both pleaded not
guilty neither one of them have cut a
deal which i think actually is what's
going to happen with elizabeth holmes
i'm going to put it out there right now
i think they're going to get
two weeks into this trial and it is
going to look so bad for her that i
think she's going to cut a deal flip on
um
belwani
and uh maybe she serves i put it at
three years this is my i'm giving you my
estimate right at the beginning i think
she serves if i had to set an over under
which is like setting a line and
gambling that
has a reasonable chance of falling
either way i'm putting that 32 and a
half months i think that's where it
comes down for me no push folks uh if
she does two weeks or something like
that something funky we're not counting
it so we're going to do it in full
months so according to the wall street
journal newly public court records show
that holmes could argue that quote
she was in a decade-long abusive
relationship with former theranos
president ramesh sunny bawwani that left
her under his control obviously she's
arguing that she was under his control
during the period in which the frauds
were committed very convenient tomes
accused mr bowani of controlling what
she ate
when she slept and how she dressed
throwing shop sharp objects at her and
monitoring her text messages and emails
among other things
again all of this is according to court
documents obtained by the wall street
journal
and according to that wall street
journal article
the newly released documents were filed
in court under seal between 2019 and
2020 john carrera who is covering the
home trial in a new podcast uh titled
bad blood the final chapter called this
the svengali defense on twitter uh and
so you know the bengali defense is quote
according to uh wikipedia a legal tactic
that portrays the defendant as a pawn in
a scheme of a greater more influential
criminal mastermind
so the wall street journal also uh
noted that quote mr balwani
unequivocally denies that he engaged in
any abuse at any time according to the
newly unsealed filings the wall street
journal also interviewed a forensic
psychiatrist named jason roof for the
article and he gave the money quote here
given the complexity of a white-collar
crime over the span
of a great deal of years making the case
that the person
throughout each of these dealings was
unable to understand the nature and
quality of what they were doing is going
to be difficult roof also mentioned that
defense is rooted in manipulation and
ptsd can help explain situations where
quote brief acute episodes have really
impaired the defendant's behavior brief
and acute i think are
uh the exact opposite of how you would
uh describe the theronous fraud so while
uh this defense you would want to give
the benefit of the doubt to anybody who
was in fact abused i think elizabeth
holmes is a masterful manipulator of
people's emotions and minds and is
incredibly savvy when it comes to image
uh obviously cribbing
details of steve jobs is you know
dropping out of college wearing
turtlenecks
using his quotes mimicking his uh
you know behaviors and mannerisms and
using that deep voice this is a
completely insincere person who
orchestrated a massive fraud by all
accounts and you know just objectively
looking at what happened
and you're going to say that she was the
one who's manipulated over a decade and
was bowani there for the entire decade
because i don't think that that's the
case so what about the time she wasn't
with him was did she
do was she actually committing a fraud
and then he came and that it became a
bigger fraud you know it's i think this
is a hard one to believe
okay dell for entrepreneurs wants you to
stay connected to your business no
matter where you are in a world where
you can work from anywhere why would you
let technology hold you back you
shouldn't mobile-ready devices such as
dell's latitude line of tablets pair
with verizon to give founders the power
to stay connected wherever there is cell
phone coverage so stay productive as you
scale your business with confidence of
secure connections no more relying on
public wi-fi oh no because it's usually
way too slow and dangerous don't i know
it i was just on the road stay confident
that your connection is secure with
dell's mobile ready devices and these
are incredible you know you want to have
that built into the tablets and that's
what dell's latitude line is doing
something i care very deeply about and
you all know i love my dells i've got a
great dell computer because i like to
play a little starcraft too and man
windows is so fast and powerful on these
dell computers it's so stable i just
can't believe it and i have so many dell
monitors well i have two giant dell
monitors turned in landscaping with like
turning them instead of being white when
you just flip them so i am more
effective because i work in a dynamic
industry i gotta keep four or five
things going at once and my dell
monitors help me do that you can go to
launch dot co slash down to get
connected to marcus a manager at del for
entrepreneurs for more info and to
unlock exclusive deals like an extra
five percent off just go to launch.com
and you'll get connected to save five
percent today go to launch.com